チィーッス俺の名前は
美容師やってんだ
キラーン
みんなは俺みたいに髪の毛明るくしたことあるかい？
まぁまぁ落ち着けってみんな
まぁまここまで明るくするとなかなかね
悪くねぇーだろ
こんな髪色にするとなかなか目立つんだけども
髪の毛の色を金色からさらに明るくしたい時って
どうするかわかる？
なかなか人の髪を白色にするのって難しいんですよ
ブリーチかけまくったりするとなると思うんだけども
やっぱ大変で髪が傷んじゃったり
頭皮にダメージがいっちゃったり
なかなか白に近づくってのは難しんだけども
そんな時どうするかっていうと
パチン
ってのがあるんだ
まぁこれなんだけども
どんなもんなのかっていうのを今から紹介してくよ
まなんせトップ取ってるよねぇ
通の人からすると
って呼んでるらしいんだ
まぁ書いてある通り黄ばみを抑える
まぁ要するに見てみ俺の髪
今ぱっと見黄色いっしょ
これ黄色さを抑える為にはどうしたらいいかみんなわかる？
そう
そうすると黄色と紫が打ち消しあって白になる
それがムラサキシャンプーの原理
だから今俺この髪にムラサキシャンプーかけて
こうやってシャカシャカつって
バーって洗って戻ってくると
若干白くなってるかもしんないね
ヒャッホー
というわけで今俺ん家に金髪のやつ多いから
全員ムラサキシャンプーで髪の毛白くしていくぜ！
ヒャオー
っていう嘘です
ムラサキシャンプー名前の通り
中身が紫なんですよ
ちょっと出してみますね
ほんとにでも今言った通りで
黄色味が出てるから
紫色をちょーっと足すと
白っぽくなるって言うのがムラサキシャンプーなんですけど
まぁほんとに中身もね超紫なんですよ
うわぁやべっほら！もう超
うわぁーちょっと待って待ってって！
うわ本当こんなレベルの紫なんですよ
これを頭に塗って洗い落とすと白になるんですけども
こちらご存知でしょうか？
色んなYouTuber使ってると思うんですけども
ってやつがあります
こっちはもう本当紫味をちょっと入れて白っぽくするってやつなんですけど
こっちはゴリッゴリに
ゴリッゴリに髪の毛が紫色になるやつです
つまり今日は何がしたいかって言うと
金髪の人にムラサキシャンプー使ってみなって言うと
髪の毛が白くなるつってちょっとテンション上がっちゃうよね
そんなテンション上がりながらムラサキシャンプー
こうやってつけて洗い流すと
これムラサキシャンプーなんで中身が紫のマニックパニックってわかんないと思うんで
フフフww
これで髪の毛洗ったら
ムラサキシャンプーどころか紫になってしまうと
をやってみたいと思います
フゥゥゥゥ
俺こういう人いっちゃん嫌いなんだよな
マニックパニック時間経つと落ちるんで
しばらくターゲットに紫になって頂くんですけども
まぁすぐに直りますので
一時的に我慢して頂きましょう
ではいこう
というわけでこの中に早速マニックパニックを入れていきましょう
どこまで色が近づけるかですねポイントは
よしきた
早く早く
少なぁ
やっべぇぞ全然入んねぇ
はいというわけでできました
違うww
若干違うんですけどそんな事は大丈夫
きっとバレないと思います
では早速ムラサキシャンプーすると見せかけて
髪の毛を紫にしていこうと思います
ではいってみよう
はじめ：よーへいくーん
やふへゐ先生：はい
はじめ：おなしゃす
はじめ：こんにちはやふへゐ：こんにちは
はじめ：というわけでえー我々皆金髪になってしまったんですけどやふへゐ：はい
はじめ：更なる色の高みに目指す時どうすればいいと思います？
はじめ：チッチッチ
はじめ：ようへいくんムラサキシャンプーというものをご存知でしょうか？
やふへゐ：ありますねぇ
はじめ：知ってますこれ？やふへゐ：はい
やふへゐ：これにムラシャンするんすか？はじめ：そうです
はじめ：金髪の人にムラサキシャンプーをすると黄ばみを抑えて何か白く白に近づけるみたいな
やふへゐ：え？そうなんだはじめ：うんほら
はじめ：なんで全員ムラサキシャンプーすると全員白になれるんじゃないかっていう
やふへゐ：なるほど
はじめ：ちょっともう一段階上いきませんか？
はじめ：いきたいですか？
やふへゐ：いきたいです
はじめ：白になりたい？
やふへゐ：なりたい
はじめ：やりますか？
やふへゐ：やります
はじめ：というわけで早速ムラサキシャンプーしていきましょう
はじめ：いらっしゃいませ
はじめ：すいませんたくさん使ってしまいました
やふへゐ：ｗｗ
はじめ：失礼致しました
やふへゐ：あ
やふへゐ：まじで紫なんですね
はじめ：はい何かこれで黄色と紫が打ち消しあって白に近づくという感じらしいです
やふへゐ：じゃあいきますはじめ：はい
はじめ：あなんか部分的に白いあ！白い！
やふへゐ：え？？
やふへゐ：ホントすか？
はじめ：おーおーおーおーおー
はじめ：失礼しやす失礼しやすやふへゐ：お願いします
はじめ：ここら辺とか
はじめ：すんげー紫
はじめ：違うwww
はじめ：そんなww
やふへゐ：これ絵の具じゃないですよね？
はじめ：そんなしょうもない事しないww
はじめ：きわまでちゃんとつけてあげたい所ではある
はじめ：これで放置でございますやふへゐ：放置
はじめ：ありがとうございますやふへゐ：ありがとうございます待ちます
やふへゐ：待って！変な薬剤じゃないですよね？はじめ：違うww
はじめ：よしようへいくん
はじめ：そろそろ落としますかやふへゐ：はい
はじめ：キレイな白髪になってると思うんで
やふへゐ：えっこれ
やふへゐ：いやムラサキシャンプーって前々から聞いた事あったんですけど大丈夫ですかこれ？
はじめ：いや大丈夫です大丈夫です！
はじめ：よしじゃそろそろ時間なんで洗い流します
やふへゐ：はーいお願いします
やふへゐ：まだまだ見ない方がいいですよね？
はじめ：そうですね
はじめ：いやめっちゃキレイ
やふへゐ：どうしますか？このまま移動すか？
はじめ：このまま1回鏡見てみますか
はじめ：では…
はじめ：ご覧ください
はじめ：どうぞ！！
やふへゐ：ねぇーwwヤバい！えーはじめ：ははははwww
【はじめしゃちょー エンディング】
ははははははははははwwwww